per la tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo
tornati su happy meal kids è bello mi si
dice pronto alle tipo dalle vacanza ogni
volta che all'inizio è più se come
tornare a casa con l'estero podio ma che
bello elio che vuoi grappa armi a luke
fermi tutti cazzo non mancano a farmi
natio non riuscirci dovrà porca [ __ ]
famiglia eccola che l'ho preso lurido
stronzo pupa vero uk 6
[Musica]
ok ragazzi non riesco ad aggrapparmi ma
perché è sì no sì una sega via scafa
resto livello senza tratto you che si
aggrappa tranquillamente a suo padre e
io li tirò le lepri d'arte sulla schiena
fantastico ma qual è il punto visto
livello se devo rimanere attaccato i
proclami crescono penny non è normale
sta roba ragazzina merda loro charme
ok forse è stata un'idea del cazzo però
va bene non ho capito ma c'è dietro un
link che questo devo beccare per vincere
non lo saprò tomista il suo culo
perfetto che riuscissi anno perfetto no
l'ho preso regalo ripreso non so come ho
fatto ma dover ricorrere di morire è un
dolce questo mi piace sai dal nome non
lo shock che mimì salire gli stadi
deficiente ma dall ice il bravo bravo
nonno di testa proprio cioè il preso
come server bravo hai capito tutto dalla
vita nonno 3 cosa faccia sì bravo tutto
nel tour no sì ho vinto non facciamoci
domanda bene così non ho capito neanche
io come ho fatto ma non i por matrix
questo mi piace il gioco fatto non c'è
la schivata più bella della storia
ragazzino slider slann d'ardia wright
cos'è sta roba
non c'è un livello di slam da ragazzi
non l'ho mai visto un livello di slider
fatto così bene sui primi c'è una cosa
fantastica
c'è scritto che ho visto stronzate
questa è la prima perfetto ragazzi un
alunno di otto trovate la prima pagina
ma credo 22 perfetto sono 345 mi chiamo
non certo un affare my summer e forse
dovevo starmene zitto merda tenta lei
non è che per caso la regali non lo
tocco sto tizio mi faccia paura così
pazzo che cazzo teri d amico mio
lo posso l'ho toccato lo tocca
sicuramente fia si può andare avanti
perfetto ragazzi per me e mi ha
cresciuta sa cosa non distruttivo 7 di
otto ero già ho già vinto
o a caso va bene così ragazzi non
facciamoci domande che meglio gli input
frizzo cos'è sta roba
troppi poltrone people cos'è sta roba
ragazzi è un pivot ron questo non
lanciare persone alle spalle non le
spade alle persone fantastico ma è
bellissimo ma fermi un attimo si può
veramente ho capito ma muoio che cazzo
fai ragazzi per perché io le donne so
come prenderle non c'è dubbio siete nel
posto giusto poteva lanciare prima che
ok che io adesso mi sono fatto la
barriera perfetto sono salvo e non ho
mai fatto un livello più non senso di
questo però che i soldi sat akbar
tornava dai questo lo faccio ogni volta
ogni volta che c'è zombies ma perché
fanno fare sempre automi a nonno ciò che
sai cosa non l'ho mai capito va bene
ragazzo non importa l sono e che cosa
vuoi da me li mettono lì non è colpa mia
mi dispiace perchè lo fanno sempre farà
lui lo zombie e neanche usa sì però sei
anche stronzo è una cosa è la madonna
che mira ve lo portano a fermi a che lo
porto lo porto che è mio amico questo
arriviamo alla fine che è meglio ti sei
innamorato della mia pistola
c'è un tizio col balducci e la madre se
dispiace sta cosa ragazzi però non è
colpa mia che ho vinto perfetti nemmeno
male blend anche su questo questo mi
manca effettivamente avevo ancora fatto
in slow motion
mi dicono che c'è un mila fatevi provare
un attimino
ma questi ragazzi oggi non c'è verso non
è così che bellissima coppia ragazzi
[Musica]
no vabbè dai si dice che vota no ma
[ __ ] possono stare quanto è tutto
il giorno credo ma non perché merda che
è successo sentite ma di testa c'è
mezz'ora ragazzi per fare un canestro 1
davanti in è più iscritto livelli che
non hanno senso
cos'è l'amica va a scuola scuola
fantasma è il ritorno a scuola ragazzi
peraltro neanche a vicenda
domani tutti così ed è bello regala ecco
la libertà io vorrei reagire così ogni
volta invitando il cibo della mensa
però non posso per ovvi motivi prova
posso fare a meno su happy della scuola
durasse 24 secondi e 73 credo che ci
andrei anche volentieri giant sword
trovo cos'è sta roba mia è la madonna
che altro nobel epicità basta che poi mi
dovete spiegare perché è alto 4 metri
però prioritario la testa già la testa
striminzita mi chiamo rock swing che sia
decente per favore esattamente così
volevo proprio intendere questo
credetemi
si ok perché faccia non riesco a fare a
meno già mi piace sto livello però ho
vinto ho già vi 9 tocca ed è in questi
momenti che spider man mi fa una pippa
raga non l'ho capito bene come ho fatto
ad attaccarmi ma va bene mi sembra
giusto che prima mi si siano staccate le
braccia al momento proprio opportuno che
cosa mi si è staccata adesso la testa
fantastico almeno ho vinto ho toccato
l'ho toccato alla ragazza degli han
sesto a dondolarsi nella maniera non lo
tocco e anche qualcosa perché mi se sei
perfetto mezz'ora anche per far questo
prova ad un ken chiuse no vabbè questo
tipo bliss no anzi io ho due bambini e
il non me ne frega un cazzo
cos'è successo vuoi giocare come honda
energy che cazzo ci sono perché sa testa
mi ritorna sempre indietro non ho capito
se si è affezionata o cosa ma va bene
così ancora non so se ragazzi impossible
favi jvc prima però se ci riuscirà sarà
il migliore di tutto il mondo c'è un mio
livello ragazzo è finito nella
classifica fantastico xvi sia direi che
sono un professionista devo riuscire a
capire un attimo come bello non forte
domanda ragazze caso cosa cazzo fate è
triste perché c'è tetris veramente o
funziona veramente
no non ci fosse ma io non vedo un cazzo
come faccio mi sa che un po maga tosto
tetris però va bene così mediashopping
car cos'è sta roba
la macchina è una delle più belle che io
abbia mai visto e soprattutto credo che
non sappia guidarla il caso fosse data
la patente fammelo sapere non adesso per
curiosità si possa fare un 360 qualcosa
legge bello fantastico e nonno ho vinto
come cazzo sono rimasto siccome ragazzi
ho già provato l'imporsi come voglio
vedere se c'è già famiglia yalp un run
off avis e farmi questo livello mi rende
felicissimo
quindi da ora in avanti di kami
felicissimo ciao favi spero che ciò che
lei a questo livello sarà più
entusiasmante della tua via la madonna
importante che sto ragazzo sia sicuro ne
va bene così è bello devo andarci o
sugli arti money unico merda ma se ho
vinto quasi se riuscisse a lanciare liu
che ebbe bello gli orc bravo hai fatto
una cosa intelligente per una volta il
seggiolino ha vinto no no cosa ance
traguardo di soe sarà meglio che sto
facendo sì quei pali j i farisei golf
cos'è sta roba fatevi fare faeti poi
minico essere io li ha mossi livelli
abbiate pazienza però c'è l'ultima volta
che l'ho giocato è stato qualcosa di
fantastico
evidentemente lecciso giocare a
minigonne o lei
non a caso fa vj air to air gun cos'è
mai favi vince ma quella è leonardo
devo fare perché mi è arrivato un
arpione in bocca
cosa c'è scritto è la madonna non mi
fate neanche partire ma è possibile
ragazzi si no
a caso a caso va bene così bellissimi i
nomi ragazzi complimenti ci stiamo
avvicinando al cinquantesimo episodio di
happy meals che è veramente pazzesco
anche se il video è piaciuto messo in
passato argomento mi piace anche a
faccia di facebook come non i video
trovate la descrizione centre si dimette
noi ci rimettiamo il prossimo video
ragazzi